robert spencer as the midterms are
approaching this year and both
republican and democrat pollsters are
predicting a red wave how will the
progressive communist wing of the
democratic party fare
especially with their profoundly
anti-israel
pro-radical stances and you know i'm
talking about the squad
well whatever happens
with the elections
the squad is the wave of the future for
the democrat party
they already control the agenda
and we've already seen that the house
democrats failed to
e
even criticize ilhan omar for her
repeated anti-semitic statements
and that's going to be increasingly the
case eve particularly
if the democrats take a beating in
november
then the squad will blame the democrats
who have been more willing to compromise
and we're going to see the party move
even farther to the left if that's even
possible at this point